في غزة يؤثر سلبًا على عشرات
الآلاف من النساء الحوامل، والمستشفيات القليلة
المتبقية تكافح
تحت وطأة ضحايا الحرب،
وغالبًا ما تأخذ رعاية الأمومة الروتينية
مقعدًا خلفيًا، ويقدم لنا جاما كاراتش من شبكة سي إن إن
القصة ولكن يحذر من بعض
المشاهد.  في تقاريرها، من الصعب
مشاهدة مولودة في هذا العالم بمفردها، لا يوجد
والد
بجانبها، فقط لمسة غريبة لطفل
بدون اسم تم تسليمه عن طريق عملية قيصرية
الشهر الماضي لأم أصيبت بالفعل بجروح قاتلة
في انفجار كانت في
حاضنة  منذ أن كانت مستقرة الآن ولكن لا يزال
الأطباء هشين،
يقول الأطباء إنها واحدة من ما يقرب من 20.000
طفل يولدون في هذه الحرب كل 10 دقائق
يولد طفل في غزة. وتقول الأمم المتحدة إن غزة هي المكان الذي أصبحت فيه
بركات الحياة الآن لعنة. وعمان حامل في
شهرها الخامس مثل
معظم جيناتها.  عائلة مشردة،
مراحيض مدرسة تحولت إلى مأوى، هو
المكان الذي
يعيشون فيه أومن وزوجها بالكاد يستطيعان
إطعام أطفالهما، ليس هناك ما يكفي لطفلهما الذي لم
يولد بعد
[موسيقى]، لم
تحصل على مكملات الحديد
ولا حتى فحص طبي منذ
أشهر، مستشفيات غزة القليلة المتبقية
غارقة في
الفيضانات التي لا نهاية لها على ما يبدو من ضحايا الحرب،
ليست هناك فرصة لإجراء الرعاية الروتينية، ويتم
ترك ما يقدر بنحو 50000 امرأة حامل وأطفالهن الذين لم يولدوا بعد في
البرد، وهم في وضع محفوف بالمخاطر بالفعل
قبل الحرب الآن
أسوأ بشكل كبير حوالي 40٪ من  أصبحت جميع حالات الحمل
الآن شديدة الخطورة، وتقول مجموعات الإغاثة إن حالات
الإجهاض والولادات المبكرة والمخاض المبكر
ووفيات الأمهات أكثر
احتمالًا بالنسبة للأمهات لأول مرة، مثل هيم، حيث
طغى هذا
الوجود البائس على الإثارة التي أصبحت الآن حياتها
قريبًا لتصبح
أطفالها
بدلاً من ذلك اضطرت إلى ذلك  هربت عدة مرات
ولجأت إلى المستشفيات المزدحمة
ومشيت أميالاً بحثاً عن
الأمان بعد المشي لساعات عديدة
كنت مرهقة، وتقول إن الطفل كان
ضعيفاً للغاية وأخبروني أنني يجب أن أبقى في
المستشفى ولكن لم يكن هناك مكان لذلك اضطررت إلى
المغادرة، وهي الآن  في هذه الخيمة أنام على
أرضية رملية كيف سألد في الحرب الحرب
عندما لا أملك شيئًا للطفل ولا حليب
صناعي ولا حفاضات نحن في خيمة والجو
بارد جدًا بالنسبة لنا كيف ستكون الحياة
بالنسبة لطفل صغير يولد فيه  هذه
الظروف هي جحيم، هذا
الفصل الدراسي المحترق في ما تبقى من شمال
غزة هو المأوى الوحيد الذي يمكن أن
تجده نجود، بالكاد استطاعت أن تنجو من
القصف أثناء المخاض وتكافح من أجل
الحفاظ على صحة مولودها الجديد نظيفًا ودافئًا. لقد
فصلت الحرب نجود عن زوجها، لقد كانت
فقط  تمكنت من الوصول إليه مرة واحدة
عندما أخبرته أن لديهما طفلة،
تقضي والدة هابا نيوجيرسي أيامها في محاولة
العثور على ما تستطيع لإطعام ابنتها،
ولم يكن الأمر أصعب من أي وقت مضى أن تكوني أمًا في
غزة، كل ما يمكنك فعله هو أن تحملي طفلك
بقوة و  آمل أن تنجو كلاكما من هذا
الكابوس جاما كراتشي سي إن إن لندن